So Henry and his family were so desperate to have these epileptic seizures stop
that he agreed to brain surgery. And so the doctors, in fact, took out the
hippocampi, both sides bilaterally. And it worked, the seizures stopped in both
severity and frequency. But at a horrible cost. Henry could no longer form new
long term memories. So, for instance, he would forget what he had for breakfast
that day. He could work for hours and hours with a psychologist. But if she
went away for 15 or 20 minutes and came back, he would forget completely who
she was. He would also be able to watch TV. Follow along with the program, but
as soon as a commercial came along, he would forget what the program was and
what it was about. He also, with difficulty, with concentration, could solve a
crossword puzzle. But if he was interrupted at all, he would forget what he was
doing. And not be able to solve it.